hello to a new three minute madness and
I'm playing constant constant who is
that let me check I don't know I'm
playing the Latvia and keep getting
requests for that bloody opening so and
see what happens you know I think I made
a mistake already heck we have six is to
poop but he didn't play tweenage five I
guess he he was kind of maybe smelling a
red there or something okay so let's see
can i still get some kind of game out of
this yeah it's probably not not that bad
could be worse I mean I am worse but
it's a Latvian worst case scenario you
kind of lost on move 10 and this is not
looking like it's lost yeah anyway yeah
yeah yeah you're right you're absolutely
right my king is not safe but I kind of
knew what that this would happen okay
maybe I can disturb this Bishop a little
bit that could be an idea yeah okay but
I'm kind of happy that I that I got this
now this is not it's not that clear
actually okay he's got that pressure on
system but I can cover that
strategically speaking I'm not in bad
shape here which sounds completely crazy
if you have played the Latvian but Jim
okay so i was thinking c6 them push this
push this back
our sabers a massive my sabers
relatively King heal my king is
relatively safe I swear I didn't drink I
mean only my usual brand of
non-alcoholic beer but no no drugs in
any any shape or form so what is he
doing we should be to ASM this one kind
of crazy but oh he wants to fire you
yeah yeah yeahs night to d5 this is not
not so great okay push it f5 as around
the corner should take care of that I
don't know this is not the greatest
position ever but not sure how bad it is
debatable oh yeah 25 is coming wow I
completely completely forget it forgot
about that the Queen being able to go
them as I have staff Knight to c6 some
night a 6 is possible it not sure that
it wins now I don't think it wins
his rook is also attacked some and that
position doesn't doesn't look overly
clear time morning I have no idea what
to do him and that is six is mostly
trading stuff I don't think it did sits
that that bad hmm ok didn't think about
this riddle now come on let's get rid of
that stuff
97 or what is this and check it's not a
problem f7 he'll what's the deal wow
crazy absolutely crazy check what's this
one said I made a check check I don't
see your mate check check check yes it's
very check comfortable of course can I
can I get some check myself oops check
check check check check back correct
positioning for black check check yeah I
know mutual agreement we actually
clicked here I don't know who okay okay
sis is why should have played the king
but I can't play the cochrane gambit
here that's also cool thank you yes some
pre moves are not a good idea sorry ah
ok yeah you can play this night F 794
primo it's not a good idea it saves you
like have a second but might cost you
the odd game
okay I'm just 15 points short of them
all time high in
I give me a new black new black game for
all the Latvian or some other crazy
stuff I don't know usually that's much
more traffic in the three-minute pool
currently that's just much more we
wanted 50 km estas my parish really the
vice president of feed a ok yeah of
course I'm giving up this Pony
immediately it looks like pretty neat
compensation here of course fire Queen
85 or what are you doing nope yeah
what's completely winning here I of
course I can still screw it up but
position is fantastic
check okay nighty Shaq Roland I Texas
good so what now many good moves and I'd
have several I can also let's look back
I think this is a good one Queen doesn't
have many squares yeah check the check
and maybe be one for Bishop to b5 all
right so it's very convenient if this
this position also night XD for
what's-what's just good okay many many
good continuations I came and some
taking is good should be four is also
strong so I think Bishop e7 we need the
Queen
okay so be sure to six wins stuff or I
just got clean 85 yeah it's all good
yeah this is this is the problem here a
little bit they are all good yeah Bishop
here is really Queenie five that's it's
not not that congesting and okay so
should be 60 to how to keep keep the
Queen's on here this 495 maybe want to
play for the mayhem don't want to trade
twins I they mean I probably missed some
kind of win earlier game really should
be should be over for quite a while but
i didn't i didn't find them didn't find
the knockout so who could be five time
money and [ __ ] five
check threatening Queen d7 made now this
is Sarah not to be sniffed at now what
now will be three some play on I don't
probably probably just rugby through
twins 27 I don't see a direct win which
is kind of weird black bears eyes I ok
it's it's a position is terrible but I
would like so whenever I can take out
which probably I would have done the
rook it was just you just played the
opening in a very good way this is this
is already very dangerous and you just
didn't didn't see that I guess I don't
know it looks it looks weird anyway will
see 5 and so on ok I yes yes again I am
actually F by having my all-time high
year 23 42 I kg4 I can go be five if you
go g 4g for its strong medicine mr. as
my okie dokie you know he actually plays
normal sta starts with g four and then
place all the Sun knowledge has except
set right and is that right talk about
weird weird games
yeah what is better him unfortunately my
light 1g8 it is especially bad energy
five years really not not pleasant Wow
entirely unplayable position oh ok I g45
I know yeah maybe I should have just
played normal I mean his g4 already
pretty much was a guarantee that it
would be kind of wacky so I was ever
there was no need ready to to make it to
make it that crazy
yaquina five that was Korean c6 and yeah
that wasn't i was unbearable but he can
do probably a couple of things that
should we know you know even this even
this yeah can take the six and when I
guess it's uh it's not I shouldn't I
should not survive him t6 I mean 77 yeah
yeah I have to go there Quincy eight is
an immediate made out a king dat but
this is also also not ending well yeah
unfortunately I have to resign against
him black resins no shame this is so
this is a personal really deserves a
proper bidding anyway you can you can
google them if you like ok so the
positive thing is before that game i
have my all-time high and three minute
chest it's not bad but next time I
should really play a bit more serious
against g4 gain sign a and n see ya ok
the Latvian right okay this time I go
Queenie of six not d6 okay this first
kind of this one this one
oh my what what a bad opening anyway
we'll see what happens okay is that the
problem some wacky H porn maneuvers I'm
not sure about it hmm now that doesn't
look oh I didn't see that one coming
it's a bit of a shame okay well it's not
so bad I don't know why does he have to
play immediately and all the time is it
such an easy position i I really don't
know probably it is he already has
failed me away as complete [ __ ] after
playing the Latvian like okay this guy's
a complete [ __ ] i can play anything
maybe yeah i don't know i don't think
it's that bad by now looks kind of okay
let's see how can I somehow think I will
treat this not so maybe I can actually
do something good with this Bishop
I have absolutely no idea what this move
is about
yo it's the play of c4 maybe he just
wants to cover cover safari oh yeah I
have weird pieces here I have to admit
that
I'm trying to get the night over to f5
now it's a very strange position very
very strange time warning before oh wow
came now I didn't I did not think about
this movements it just winds the winds
upon it it is so entirely anti
positional that I didn't think about it
it is a good move for him I haven't had
simply didn't consider very weird moves
what oh my god i don't i don't
anticipate a single move here in this
game Wow
yeah it's even threatening bloody made
down oh my checkmate yes what kind of a
game was that I didn't get it did I
didn't get anything in this game I had
absolutely no idea what happened from
the first move basically we played all
this immediately and it actually was was
worse here and then he played the
weirdest maneuvers ever and somehow got
a good position here I mean I must have
brk/a blunder that wondered 97 ER this
is the thing if i play know who I'm
still ok him and he's got that all those
pieces are weird but I played I just
blundered to fire you just I just
planted it in one move something like
that is just good for luck those pieces
may don't don't make any sense not a not
in the slightest anyway I don't get
again started playing sweet sweet King
come on now the night over ok this is
also interesting The Rose of this is
also leading to very sharp positions
that too early maybe it is right I don't
know f3 geforce what often happens save
it I know that sometimes sometimes this
is happening
then g4 isn't even that great if i'm not
mistaken but ok I I know I simply have
no other idea again so so so again I
have to admit smell when he had here and
now i have to probably play this kind of
stuff which is always good night before
maybe even ok check yeah this is
socially okay if I'm um there's no I
don't have this is G for business
doesn't really help you in this position
and he just as nicely centralized yeah
that's not I cannot attack yeah
unfortunately I have to play those those
somewhat meek moves
hmm man who taking this night is
absolutely well yeah leads to a very
prospectus position so I'm playing this
but this also looks shaky even a five is
a very decent move you know yeah I
cannot go away for here comes the night
and some if four is a pretty big threat
maybe this I can get away for 94 93 here
okay does it doesn't do it it takes a am
Bishop f4 is a threat okay i can go
queen g5 here in this position I think I
will I don't really I mean okay this is
he will see the medium but it's still a
lot of bad move i think
it's not so clear actually what he does
because I'm also threatening Bishop c4
it's not not so easy maybe he has to
play some hmm I don't know what you
should do here 95 maybe 95 m yeah yeah I
can play Bishop c4 the thought that
would win win material maybe he has some
intermediate moves but currently I don't
see it Quincy for Queen d8 so yeah so we
have no intermediate both rock d1 fancy
move name let's not be fancy okay Quinn
age five doesn't time morning doesn't
really do much maybe just back him
I hope cheeks blunder this but okay I
can go for an e5 and disposition Knight
f3 maybe force the Queen trade I cannot
actually let's do this check check check
check not too easy what is he doing here
time-wise I don't get it check check
check okay it is a stupid like what this
is totally stupid him what I'm doing I
cannot win anyway I only have a night
yeah I have to perpetual him of course
it was totally stupid I can only get a
draw anyway this is this is it was
completely completely wacky okay so
before I can do the touch again come on
nobody plays the main line here this is
this is very boring guys I mean okay I
do the same stuff
h4 h5 wow this is the most urgent thing
you have to do a yellow push the age
pawn yeah maybe
yeah I never really felt that this kind
of position should threaten black much I
play this ninety three bishops you find
myself but I don't take on f6 so early
now he's taking taking ages what is he
going for you there Wow usually you go
to f4 because the night now is has
absolutely no perspective they are on g3
check to h1 ok
mysterious it's all very mysterious
okay I try to reroute this night to e4
high position is still very very solid
four wide as i said i didn't understand
the whole stuff but it's still not like
he's losing anything the position is
just it's just too too solid for that
you can do a 4 here md4 hangs but Queen
ADA's is coming hmm kind of sick of all
that shuffling around oh come on i'm
just doing I'm just I'm just firing now
here and see what he does wants to try
it okay so let's play this ending here
I've got three points now and a pretty
active position especially as some okay
go I go up with the King first let's go
over them
want to keep and keep this on the board
okay the ship is 6 yeah I guess snide
now is completely dominated so it should
be a fairly easy win check check check
33 let's see you know it let us win d3
d2 and so on hi morning what is this
okay let's make sure I keep keep some
cons here like resigns okay there's no
prisoners here in search of a little bit
at least the ask my games were cool but
it's very difficult and I mean d4f five
is kind of almost a sharpest you can do
and with those kind of sidelines where
white shuffles around it's not getting
getting that crazy okay Sicilians and
the white games master and now three
minute was actually a little bit more
more traffic but I don't get a game
game started see you oughta okay okay
yeah i mayn't I dragon this is kind of
this is very crazy for for me I have no
idea here I know that this is kind of
this is a theoretical I'm g4 is placed
Knight f3 I guess right I guess I
already have no idea night at 393
bishops III that looks dangerous
yeah this is very very dangerous for me
a pep it playing this with my knowledge
my knowledge is zero it really is just 0
okay I probably have to avoid Q&A one so
what's the deal here night c4 chief is
chief floor okay yeah I just I just go
for it night c4 I don't know if this is
some dangerous and we just goes back
okay mmm so f for again 94 I guess hmm
this one maybe this one here not c4
looks super dangerous actually it looks
winning this this is winning now takes
rook takes and I have no threat I should
have inserted queen age five I guess
yeah nothing that I can do now check I
had this one okay now that's a that's a
design that the main I dragon is
absolutely unplayable with my knowledge
it's just I cannot do it I mean I would
lose against anybody as we has this as
was proposed proven here I have no idea
about this at least that's nothing I
cannot play it in a three minute game
this is here it's already lost I just
asked the engine that is losing here I
cannot I cannot prevent his attack Wow
start okay awesome way again with this
[ __ ] g4 stuff yes okay playing a
main line now and see what he does with
that
yeah Black is giving up an exchange
share for for compensation hopefully
this is er seems completely crazy night
be 597 you got to be kidding me 96 Wow
okay so what now I can take their hmm
but I don't want to take you actually
this is looking a lot better
centralizing 96 coming m95 and then it's
got Quintus is six no he doesn't don't
understand to move so I'll go for it
yeah I can take here right this should
be quite good I think but how exactly
Knight f3 is covered how to do that
right this is not working just see three
around okay that just touches fire c 3
and c and see what happens
okay yeah I could see for i'm actually
threatening 93 check so his queen is
attack now and this rook
huh I don't know that looks like winning
what his rook has attacked his queen is
attacked I don't see a move let's see
how does he continue here yeah this is
what you can try it Jack I'll just take
tons of material now Jay we should check
her cell made somewhere yeah that's
enough check checkmate yeah as I
mentioned earlier he deserves a proper
bidding okay um one more yeah let's go
for one more one more game yeah that
line near this sacrificial mind is is I
think objectively just good for black
and in a three minute game hmm I'll take
the black position in our game starting
ok mr. cissus time for the Kings gambit
you proved Knight f6 on as he did
earlier some some wacky primo yeah
teenage force unfortunately now an
ending it's a good ending but it's not
it's not the kind of action that you
would like to get from a king's gambit
you know Matt okay I'm I'm happy in the
position is good so it's no need to
complain here slightly more active here
White's position and he does not pay any
attention to my moves okay I'll take the
porn if you if you are so kind to give
it to me ok so it's so no t6 probably
they're just going back is good
yeah it looks noise c6 know Wow friends
25 oh wow I know I was just I was just
not paying any attention it was such a
such a good position I said any
movements or what I didn't really didn't
look I didn't look at this wow what a
shame was such a nice position yeah
let's still play a couple of moves I'm
in here and many weird decisions earlier
you never know what is coming up with
check this is this is one of those but
it's from you not bad enough that it
loses or makes them what makes them
makes it difficult but you never know a
94 is unfortunately and coming check
okay so let's see how is what kind of
winning plan he has if he has one so 4
p's up so you should find something
true of country have three immediately
and you may it's not a not a big deal
j well it's not really really
interesting i mean he still wins but as
I say he played it in such a weird way
that I'm getting interested again in the
game okay that's a good move
unfortunately check it gets interesting
again okay maybe this one phones are
kind of active time Barney possibly have
to go here it's still winning it's still
bidding for black but he tried very hard
to screw it up check
Wow check very lucky man 30 so managed
two genders check check okay yeah I was
a deposit it was I was almost back in
this here it's a draw after b7 yeah of
course I wanted to be now I didn't want
to draw any more but yeah this is this
what's this what's this wasn't good it
wasn't good anyway it's not to be taken
too seriously those games I hope you
enjoyed the ride there was some some
funny games in there thanks for watching
guys